and yesterday i think chris was
the most significant day yet in
something that's only been around for
three weeks and one day it was three
weeks ago last night that we first
became aware
that there was any controversy involving
desean watson
yesterday a press conference was held by
tony busby and i've had concerns about
the way he's conducted himself and i've
had concerns about how he's made it
about him and i've had concerns about
some of the things he said
that are disingenuous but what he did
yesterday is what he should have done
all along
now it took some time to get one of the
alleged victims to the point where she
was comfortable
coming forward and speaking but it
shouldn't be about the lawyers
it should be about the individuals and
yesterday chris
it became about the individuals we know
of two names
of people who have sued desean watson
one of them
actually spoke at the press conference
yesterday and
uh it changed everything having a name
a face and a voice changes everything
from the perspective of the people who
are witnessing these events play out
it does it hits home more you know yeah
now you got a name a face
you know you see the emotions it kind of
hits home to the fact of like
you know the damage that could be done
to these people and the psychological
issues or whatever
i mean yeah it definitely you know hits
hard as far as that's concerned and you
know
when when i saw that news break
yesterday and yeah
it makes you perk up in your seat and
read into it and and all of those things
so
uh it definitely gives it a more real
sense
after yesterday um and i don't know mike
i mean
what was your overall thoughts on the
day just all together
i think it was a horrible day for
deshaun watson i think it was horrible
yeah i think it was horrible i think it
was horrible in every respect
the press conference was horrible for
deshaun watson the response by rusty
hardin his lawyer which we'll discuss
later
in the program was horrible and that was
a just a a just a huge regrettable
mistake and i i think that that
it it's all different now and it's all
changed for me now
and as i'll explain later in the program
i think the league has no choice but to
put him on the commissioner exemplars
now not later
not just well there's no football season
now there's no football activities we'll
just ignore it
i think it's too significant now to
ignore it
and i think it's it's resonating enough
with the average football fan that i
think reasonable people are wondering
why does the nfl have its head in the
sand on this it's not enough to issue
a periodic statement we'll share their
statement later but i just think it was
a bad day for desean watson and
look whatever happened happened and
whatever will happen will happen if he's
responsible for the things he's accused
of doing he deserves
to face a reckoning yeah i've argued
over the past couple of weeks
the best way to do it is voluntarily
face your reckoning
work these claims out work them out to
everyone's satisfaction
resolve this matter as quickly as you
can while also understanding what you
did and providing some form of justice
to those who have been wronged
there's 22 different people they're
going to have 22 different stories it's
not going to be easy to do
otherwise this thing is going to linger
and hover for a year or two or longer if
he digs in and
fights and my concern is that he's going
to dig in and fight
when maybe he shouldn't yeah and again
we'll talk about that more and
and this is one of the reasons why i
feel this way what we're going to do now
we're going to play the statement from
yesterday of
ashley solis it's over five minutes long
but i think it's important don't change
the channel
if you want to understand this case and
if you want to have the same human
reaction that people had yesterday when
they saw
and heard the words from ashley solis
you owe it to yourself to just
hear her out dejean watson's got the
ability to be heard out whenever he
wants
he can he can have a press conference
anytime he wants and talk about this
she chose to do so yesterday she's the
first of the 22 plaintiffs who came
forward with name
face and voice and here she is from
yesterday at the tony busby press
conference this is ashley solis the
first person who sued
desean watson three weeks ago
my name is ashley solis remember that
name
i hope every woman or man out there who
is a survivor hears my story
and i hope my story gives him courage to
speak out
it has taken me a long time to get to
this point
to come out publicly and speak my truth
i know a lot of you are probably
wondering who i was or if i even existed
i was afraid i'm not afraid anymore
and i do exist
i'm here to take pac uh take back the
power
and take back control i am a survivor of
assault and harassment
lashon watson is my soldier and my
harasser
desean watson assaulted and harassed me
on march 30th
2020 in my own home
doing what i love most massage therapy
i am a licensed massage therapist now
that that
that profession that i love so much has
been forever tainted
i'm deeply saddened but not surprised to
see so much victim blaming in the press
and by online commenters and they have
absolutely no idea
what i'm going through or what happened
to me no idea
this incident has impacted me in many
ways
and those ways are hard to describe i
feel a range of emotions
guilt embarrassment shame
courage anger sadness and numbness
some days i feel like a hero other days
i feel like a failure
i replay the incident over and over in
my head as if i'm trying to wake up from
some horrible nightmare
only that nightmare is real i blame
myself at times which is insane
society has grown women to believe that
it's their fault when they're harassed
or assaulted
as if somehow we ask for it or
somehow we could have prevented it
i can no longer practice the profession
that i love the most without shaking
during the session
my hands shake whenever i place them on
a cling and i've had to cut
sessions short
if you only knew how heartbreaking that
is to me
i got into massage therapy to heal
people
to heal their minds and bodies
to bring peace to their souls deshaun
watson has robbed me of that
he took that away from me he tainted a
profession in which i take enormous
pride
flashes of watching space rush to me
in the moment i think of his penis
touching me
which sends me into a tailspin
i suffer from panic attacks anxiety and
depression
i am in counseling as a result of this
sean watson's
actions i hope he knows how much pain
he's inflicted on me emotionally and
physically
and i hope he knows how much pain he has
inflicted
on these other survivors
my father who was once a die-hard texans
fan
can no longer mention his name without
turning red seating with disappointment
i think that that's the most
heartbreaking aspect of it all
we were all deceived into thinking
deshaun watson was a good guy
and unfortunately we know that good guys
can do terrible things
this incident is a part of me but it's
not all of me
i will not let desean watson define who
i am
i will not let him win he needs to be
held accountable for his actions
i will not let him take my power away
i am stronger now and i know who i am
people say that i'm doing this just for
money that is false
i come forward now so that desean watson
does not assault another woman
and i come forward now in the hopes that
no other human being
will assault another in the future i
want to prevent this type of conduct
i come forward now to bring change in
our society
i am seeking justice not just on behalf
of myself but for all of survivors
i stand with you all is it about having
my voice heard
this is about having other survivors
voices heard
my name is ashley solis and i am a
survivor
me too thank you
again that was essence elise yesterday
at the press conference held by tony
busby the first person to come
forward name face and voice and it's a
powerful
five minutes and it does change
everything because it gives anyone who's
paying attention chris
something tangible someone that they can
relate to someone that they can
see a sister a niece a spouse a
girlfriend a cousin
someone they know it's it's just not
jane doe
and i i can't help but wonder whether or
not rusty harden's strategy
of constantly pushing this issue of
who are these women they're all jane doe
they're all jane doe suggesting they
didn't
even exist at times if you read between
the lines i wonder how much of that
ended up fueling the desire by ashley
solis to make sure that people
saw her and heard her and realized there
are real human beings who are making
these 22 claims against desean watson
yeah i mean
i don't know how you can watch that and
not feel compassion for her
you know that i mean the the immediate
response
on reading the statement itself
you could tell how shaken she is
by the situation and that she's got to
go back there in her mind
to that moment once again you know that
that to me is where it
it for all those people out there who
were doubting this right
and you're going oh 22 people and they
never went to the cops and do those
things
when you see that that answers a lot of
that for at least for me
because it's just as a woman and men
can't understand this because we're a
different animal than women all together
it's just we're a different species
but as a woman to go to the cops and
make something like that public
it's not easy it's not easy just to do
that and now bring attention
on that and now my family knows my
personal life and i gotta look at my dad
who knows these things went on and now
they're in his head and i got to look at
my dad and i'm thinking that he's
thinking that
you know that's where uh
you know just it gives me it's a i have
a lot of compassion for her that was i
was brave on her part
and uh i i would hope for the people out
there who right now
think that this is you know and again i
was one of those on the fence this is
fishy this is weird
but we are at 22 people now 22 people
and then 18 others who came out and you
know again
defended him but that's still weird
that's still it's 40 masseuses it's
unheard of in the history of football
nobody has 40 masseuses so
i i don't know but yes that's that's a
tough moment for desean watson and his
team because i would think a lot of
people are going to watch that and
realize that like listen she's not that
great of an actor to be doing that that
was real
you could tell there was something very
real and tangible about it and
um yeah i think it puts watson and his
his camp in a very very tough position
as we go forward here
we're going to pivot back to the point
of the 18 massage therapists who spoke
out in support last week of deshaun
watson because that also is backfiring
i know sorry i didn't harden but that's
okay no i just wanna i wanna
transition to lauren baxley who was not
present yesterday but she has disclosed
her identity she is one of the others
who
have come forward now but not face and
voice
name so far wrote a letter to deshaun
watson
at the recommendation of her counselor
as a way to
process and heal one of the lawyers from
tony busby's firm
read the letter yesterday during the
press conference
and it was similar in many respects to
the things that ashley solis
said every boundary from professional
therapeutic to sexual and degrading you
crossed is what
lauren baxley said to sean watson in
this letter you're nothing more than a
predator with power
your good guy persona is nothing more
than a meticulously designed facade to
keep
your victims silent and
that's where we are so far now tony
busby also spoke chris
about the pattern of behavior the things
he did these are allegations
and as i said deshaun watson is free to
fill
the vacuum of silence on his side any
time he wants understanding anything he
says can and will be used against him in
civil court potentially criminal court
but he doesn't have to remain
silent in the face of this here's what
busby said yesterday about this pattern
in which he alleges watson engaged
each of the cases makes a describing
or describes a strikingly similar
pattern of behavior
watson reaches out to uh women on social
media particularly
instagram he asks for a massage even
though
some of these women were not massage
therapists and were doing other types of
work but he
specifically asked for a massage and
when they say i don't do massages he
asks them well can you do a massage
watson arranges the appointment on
social media again particularly
instagram
he repeatedly insists that the woman be
alone
citing privacy concerns and in some
cases he even dictates that what he
wants
the particular woman to wear in some
cases he takes
pictures of the particular woman from
instagram
and sends it to her and says wear
something like this because it's
hot today or it's hot in houston
he insists repeatedly even when told
that it's not
normal to use a towel for cover
in most cases he insists on bringing his
own towel
what the towel is instead is a small
washcloth
in some cases he asked the woman to sign
a non-disclosure agreement before the
session
and in some cases he asked the woman to
sign the non-disclosure agreement
after the session
you know other things that tony busby
said chris beyond that
pattern in which he alleges watson
engaged
there were times where he got referrals
to massage therapists from members of
the texans organization there were times
he borrowed tables
from the texans for these massage
sessions and
even though he was careful not to say
he's not accusing the texans of anything
at one point he said at some point you
have an obligation to ask questions when
something doesn't add up
we have massage therapists on staff
if you are engaging these
private individuals for separate
sessions on such a frequent basis
what's really going on here and i
suspect he'll explore that
as part of his duty to his clients
because if there is an argument to be
made eventually in good faith with the
support of the relevant texas laws
that there was some negligence by the
texans that they knew or should have
known that watson was engaged in this
misconduct and they didn't shield
these individuals from it in fact they
referred him to them
that that that becomes a potential
legal quandary for the houston texans
and it's clear that busby is going to
investigate it whether it goes anywhere
is a different issue
but it's clear from what he said
yesterday he's going to investigate well
and and
then the thing that jumps out to me
about more than any of that and that'll
dispel
the again i'm gonna state this i was one
in that camp
right this is a little fishy i don't
know it just seems weird
well deserve a connection between him
and cal mcdair and the houston texans is
this something that's where they've
gotten together
and conspired and knew this was going on
and now
you know have done this to deshaun
watson when you hear that yesterday that
that ends that
that that's at least what it did for me
when you when you go oh i mean if he
attacks the houston texans and then
starts to bring litigation upon them
then yeah no they're they're not in
cahoots together in some grand
conspiracy to bring deshaun watson down
because he's a power player in houston
and wanted out of the houston texans
organization
i think that's the the biggest tell to
me with that because i think
mikey i mean you look on social media
that's that's the big thing
right now on social media is people
questioning the realness of this is
there a conspiracy behind it
it's so odd that he was about to be
traded and then this came out and all of
that
and i'm just saying these things to
maybe help some of those who are on
social media and they're watching to go
wait no that that doesn't add up we got
to stop with that excuse
and your reaction chris and their
reaction is not
unreasonable because of the way this all
played out that's right right tony busby
was the one who was front and
center the circumstances suggested based
upon the way he was conducting himself
the things he was saying
remember the first press conference when
he on his own
raises these silly rumors about some
sort of connection with the texans and
he pretends not to know cal mcnair's
first name
how does he not know cal mcnair's first
name little things like that
fed into the idea that something was
fishy and it
it never should have been about the
lawyers it never should
have been about tony busby it should
have always been about the individuals
and i couldn't help but wonder yesterday
whether he just has managed to execute
some sort of elaborate rope-a-dope
on desean watson and rusty harden to set
up what happened yesterday i don't know
that
any lawyer is smart enough to pull off
what has happened
deliberately but he what do you mean by
robodope like why what what did he do to
the
yeah that just the way he was handling
things the way he was conducting
himself the way he was making it look
like he was in it for publicity
he was planting these seeds that were
causing people to reasonably say
something's not right here something's
fishy i have questions i have doubts
right and then all of a sudden ashley
solis shows up yesterday
and anyone who had doubt says oh my god
yeah it's got a lot more impact
if it happens that way if he's managed
to
to create doubt in his own cause for
three weeks
and then you bring out victim number one
who tells a compelling story at a time
when people like you
people like me other people have just
been like something's not right
something doesn't add up right i think
it's a lot more impactful that's what
i'm saying it's a little bit of a rope i
got you i got you where right
he drew us in he drew watson in he drew
harden in and we're all thinking
it's a little wobbly and then and then
he delivers the knockout punch and trust
me
nothing happens accidentally even though
we witnessed what we believe is a very
real
human moment yesterday from ashley solis
this is all being orchestrated and
strategized by the lawyer in an effort
to best represent her and the rest of
the clients and it worked
and it worked for as much as it it may
not have worked the first three weeks
it worked yesterday so that's my point
and and if it was deliberate
it's genius because there were questions
that were
swirling and i think anyone who paid
attention to yesterday's press
conference those questions
for the most part have been resolved
they they should be i i i mean i agree
with you there
but but i don't think they're resolved
because of the other
aspect of the you know and i don't want
to jump the gun here on our program but
i mean it's just coming up kind of
organically here
of the hundred thousand dollar right
quit the the civil hey we'll we'll keep
this out of a
uh you know the courtroom and all that
if you pay
you know so lease a hundred thousand
dollars
right so that is the other aspect that i
know just looking at social media that
jumps out to me now
there's that camp there that just goes
well they're back into the
well you see that it is about the money
which
again is wrong i don't agree with that
but there's too many people who just
take little snippets and snippets and
snippets and they lose the context of
the situation or know nothing about the
situation all together
and they're just going at it at a very
base face level that way
and that's uh the the other thing i
guess that now busby's gonna have to
deal with the two to a degree part of
the problem
is that people are behaving the way that
we behave on all matters
of politics or strong everything or
anything like that because
we have our position that we establish
why that with no facts i don't know but
we establish our position
and then every additional fact
is run through our position and warped
into a way that supports our position
without us
ever having the the the courage or
right yeah
to take a step back and say maybe my
first reaction
right wrong right maybe circumstances
have
changed maybe i should have kept an open
mind and and i think
that that uh there will be some who
still continue to to listen to the
argument and process this notion that
it's just a money grab
because it started as an attempt to
resolve the case without litigation and
that
was the gist chris yeah of the rusty
hardened statement yesterday right
it was a long statement it was way too
long general pr advice to any lawyers or
anyone else out there put it down
if your statement looks long it's long
yeah and
and look at that look at that you need a
microscope go through right now
exactly i mean this day so people can't
keep their attention for four seconds
it's too long
if you can't make your point quickly
maybe it's a point that shouldn't be
made but what harden is trying to say
and this is where i think his first
mistake happens
yeah he's trying to paint ashley solis
as a liar when she says
that it's not just about the money
people say i'm just
doing this for money doing this just for
money that was one of her quotes and
they highlight in the first paragraph of
the statement
and she says that is false so he takes
aim at that right
by rewinding to february when the
circumstances were very different
and disclosing details that supposedly
are confidential between the lawyers
when
these things happen and and here's what
i want people to understand because
harden uses a pejorative term hush money
they sought hush money look this is the
way the legal system works i was in it
for 18 years
yeah both finances people don't get this
yeah yeah
and this happens very very frequently
now sometimes you decide
it's not worth even trying or there's an
element of surprise that you want to
preserve
by suing first and then
having settlement discussions later but
in a case like this when you're dealing
with a high profile person
who does not want or shouldn't want
controversies like this attached to his
or her name
there is value in approaching the person
ahead of time
and saying here is my grievance
this is my concern this is what happened
and i am giving you an opportunity to
resolve the case
resolve the grievance resolve the claim
now
before we go to court and people think
that's extortion it's not this is the
way the sausage gets made
legitimately and legally in the legal
profession every
single day it's incredible sometimes
it's well well it's always encouraged to
settle yeah
and you're at some point in almost every
jurisdiction in the united states
after you file the lawsuit the judge
will require you to try to settle the
case but
in a case like this you go to the
defendant ahead of time you have the
conversation with the lawyers
and rusty harden disclosed all of the
emails the back and forth
and it's amazing to me some of the
things that were disclosed because it
at one point and and and this is where
you know
the hundred thousand dollar demand and
folks look
i i don't know much about the legal
climate in houston
but for the allegations that are being
made here and all things considered
a hundred thousand dollars as an opener
as an open sea that's the other thing
that people are losing sight of
yes that's an opener when you demand a
hundred thousand dollars
pre-lawsuit in the first number that you
put on the table when negotiating with
the lawyer who represents the person
against whom the claim is made yeah
that means you're gonna move south of a
hundred you don't start at a hundred and
say it's a hundred or nothing i was
surprised
number two i i thought it was low okay
so i'm good to god
so yeah so the way it's supposed to work
is
you start at 100 and then there's a
response by the defendant
and then there's a movement but it's
it's a very and it's amazing to me and i
remember being surprised by this because
you go to law school and you emerge from
the process and you think things are a
certain way and it's all very idealistic
and everything is handled and justice is
blind and
and then you realize at the end of the
day a lot of this process is no
different than haggling over how much
you're going to pay for a pound of
coffee in a marketplace and that's what
it comes down to
that's how people's rights are resolved
two lawyers going back and forth
until they reach a middle ground and
what happened here was and i
i think based on my own experience if
you open with 100
you're willing to settle between 50 and
75 that's the signal that you're sending
and and in hindsight desean watson
what if i'll have 50 to 75 000
to avoid this sold you know now now i
don't know how many
other claims would have been made yeah
but i think part of what happened here
is
at some point along the way they pissed
off tony busby and it motivated him to
dig a little bit more
and dig a little bit more maybe all this
stuff would have inevitably come out at
some point
right but it motivated busby to say well
uh
listen they and he says in one of his
emails that you need to look into who
you're dealing with and he dug and he
dug and he dug
but but the point is that the lawyer who
was representing desean watson's
interest at the time decided not to
respond to a hundred thousand basically
said in a somewhat condescending way
well we need more facts or we need a
different number see that violates the
etiquette there's an etiquette there
it's like a christmas story you know i
double dog daria triple dog day there's
they skip steps
he violated the etiquette by not
responding just respond with 10
000 if you think it's too much and then
see what they do
but when you go back to somebody who's
made a hundred thousand dollar demand
and say we don't like that we'll make
another
that's never going to fly
and it didn't fly here and the worst
part about all of this and i still can't
believe chris that they put these emails
voluntarily out into the public
consciousness the email from the lawyer
representing
the interests of deshaun watson before
rusty harden was involved right
said we don't believe the alleged facts
show that desean did anything wrong with
regards to ms solis but we are
nevertheless happy to continue the
conversation around a reasonable
settlement figure
because we believe he can learn a lesson
about having put himself in this
situation that's weird
yeah and they disclosed this yesterday
right as part of a statement that they
thought
was in some way going to serve as the
magical silver bullet
that eviscerated everything ashley solis
said yesterday chris i can't
believe this and and frankly well it's
too late now for desean watson and i
understand look what happens is you get
a big name lawyer and oh rusty harden
let's go get rusty hard well i remember
rusty harden screwing things up for
roger clemens in my opinion i don't want
to get sued by rusty harden right but i
remember following the roger clements
case saying
is this the best advice yeah that roger
clemens could possibly get because he
ended up
prosecuting for perjury i believe yeah
as a hung jury
i may be getting my baseball steroids
liars wrong here
you can have a whole set of trading
cards just of those guys
but i i just remember thinking rusty
harden is not the
the uh the epitome of legal brilliance
that we are being
led to believe he is in connection with
the clements case definitely in this
case in my opinion got to make sure it's
my opinion as
someone who practiced law for 18 years
that statement never should have been
issued well it never should have been
issued yeah i'm with you there busby
seems like he's more with the times and
knows how to work all the angles and
he's
yeah he's he's johnny lawyer and
annoying and brash and in your face and
certainly seems like a jerk
in a lot of ways you know um but but at
the same time he's extremely effective
that that's the one thing he's won the
the court of public opinion
like you said i i it does almost seem
like it was a little bit of a setup like
hey come on come here and then as soon
as they got close boom here's a haymaker
oh yeah right i mean yes it rusty harden
has not um
amazed me either at this point and i
know nothing
that i wanna here's the point that i
wanna make clear if you it
we always as lawyers as adversaries the
whole idea is
you try to get to the truth by pitting
two sides against each other and having
them fight it out and the thought is the
truth is somehow going to pop up in the
process so it's always adversarial
you're always fighting
and you're always trying to paint the
other side is lying in some way and if
you can do that
if you can successfully show that the
other side is lying
you've done 98 of your job but
you better make sure the thing you're
attacking really is a lie
when ashley solis says yesterday people
say i'm doing this just for money that
is false
she didn't it was just for no just for
my she didn't say
that it's false that money isn't part of
it money is part of it now money's part
of the civil justice system
the way the system works the way the
pre-litigation
settlement works it's all normal sure
there's nothing that there's nothing and
and i
this is what disappoints me because
rusty harden is is warping the way
the legal system works he's trying to
make people think that anytime this
happens
it's somehow extortion it's untoward
it's hush money
it's normal yes this is what you do
right there's nothing that i saw
yesterday in that statement or in those
emails that made me think there was
anything improper
and yes at one point in the process
if i can have my concerns resolved
quietly without having to potentially
turn my life
upside down and speak to the world
for five minutes with a statement if i
can avoid that
then yeah i'll take this payment because
that's my form of justice
sure see when you and she can't massage
anymore and she's been affected that way
which yeah i mean it's affecting her
life her money everything
sorry but but here's the thing i want
people to understand yeah when you've
been
wronged by someone by conduct that very
well may cross the line
into criminal misbehavior part of the
victim's
power is to pick the type of justice
that he or she is going to pursue
you can go to the cops if you want to
you don't have to
you can file a civil lawsuit and you
have the full extent of the applicable
statute of limitations
to wait and anyone who says why'd you
wait doesn't matter
it's within your rights to wait yeah you
can you can pursue
justice in a wide variety of ways
and it's up to the victim to decide how
to do it and ashley solis had chosen a
different way
and when deshawn watson's lawyers
essentially gave them the middle finger
they chose a different way yeah that's
all that is that's what bothers me about
this because
for the same reasons i believe tony
busby was being disingenuous early on
rusty harden in this statement
everything about it to me is wrong
it's disingenuous and it's in an
improper distortion
of the way the legal system works chris
and that's what bugs me the most i i
agree well again it goes back to
something you know yeah we're being you
know the society's being misled to think
that
normal practice here is not normal just
to defend
my client to make it look like this was
wrong and the
the court of public opinion again that's
where it goes to and that's frustrating
because that just goes on
everywhere all right i know we got to go
to a break and because no no we don't
yeah but you know but i want i want to
do one more thing before we go because
okay well
you you mentioned how effective tony
busby has been right and i've been
critical of his ways in the past right
but
but this goes back to trying to win in
the court of public opinion you think
you have a silver bullet it ends up
being a boomerang i think it's important
that we play this
the 18 individuals last week who went on
the record with their names with
statements supporting desean watson
that was a moment where like wow hey
here we are we got 22 people we don't
know who they are we don't even know if
they exist
right we got 18 who are supporting
deshaun watson
yesterday tony busby took that
supposed silver bullet and turned it
back around onto sean watson listen to
busby from yesterday
one of these individuals that was
released
said i've been providing massage therapy
to deshaun in
2018 and massaged him at least 40 times
since then
i've never had a single uncomfortable or
inappropriate experience with deshaun
that was the statement that was released
but let me read to you
the direct message that this individual
sent that we now have a copy of
i told you i stopped working with him
yeah why
because i was hearing too much stuff
about him messing with other people like
other therapists and estheticians he's
been doing a lot the last three or four
months
i even told his ass he needed to be
careful because his name getting around
i just hope don't nobody call me to
question me
yeah that's too different um yeah
somebody did their homework
on the individual yeah whose quote was
used last week and somebody else didn't
do their homework
and there's 17 others see that's what's
been set up now and the battleground
always shifts and changes when you get
into litigation
because one side will try to make
something an issue so all right let's
explore it you got these 18 people
all right let's let's do our homework
let's vet this a little bit oh you
didn't vet it
too bad for you we're going to vet it
and look what they found
and and and even you know as we said
last week
just because 18 people had experiences
with desean watson where
nothing improper happened doesn't mean
the other 22 are lying yeah possible
everyone's telling the truth
right so but but this this now
this now uh makes it even worse for
desean watson when one of these 18
people who supposedly were rushing to
his defense last week has these direct
messages
where she's according to tony busby
acknowledging
that she was aware of his reputation to
the point where
something needed to be said to him
because word's getting around it's just
it
it's it all adds up to my belief chris
that yesterday was a
very bad day for deshaun watson and for
his legal team
yeah i i'm with you mike i mean it is a
really really bad day
um i guess the next and it should be if
he's guilty it should be
see i try to separate my analysis of
what's happening in the court of public
opinion potentially court of law from
what actually occurred
if he's guilty of these things it should
be a bad day
and he should have many more bad days
until he has his reckoning and makes
things right uh agreed mike i mean
agreed there's no doubt so i i i mean
the next thing here and and i just
to me as someone here again not a lawyer
football fan used to be a desean watson
fan
not right now i could tell you that but
like
you see ashley solis the other comments
busby out there at what point
like again if rusty harden and desean
watson want to claim the innocent
card and you know whatever extortion or
anything
like that i mean at what point does
desean watson got to show his face
and get in front of a camera and we got
to see his emotions and how he answers
or says certain things
you know and how his face looks because
ashley solis
the way she said that it had real power
to it and
i i kind of think at this point too this
far in like
deshawn's desean watson's silence is
kind of deafening at this point uh in
this situation
anything you say can and will be used
against you in a court of law and that
is true in civil court and criminal
court and that's the balance that they
have to strike because as i said earlier
he's free to make a statement for five
minutes or longer he can call a press
conference he can do an interview
there are plenty of platforms where he
can get a message out
other than something that was written on
a notes app and
pasted to social media three weeks ago
that's the only thing we've heard
directly
from desean watson right the problem is
most lawyers who like to preserve their
ability to win in court eventually would
say
don't do it don't do it don't do it and
i think that's part of the problem here
you got rusty harden who's a criminal
lawyer
dealing with civil cases dealing with
court of public opinion
it's it you almost i know it's not the
right ring
yeah yeah you you need a pr specialist
to deal with the court of public opinion
a civil law specialist to deal with the
civil cases and a criminal law
specialist
to deal with those and ultimately what
you needed was someone
to get to deshaun watson early on
speak a hard truth to him get him to
realize
the ways the dominoes could fall that
could derail his career or worse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports